jonathan stevert 23 years old on the
mound for the first time in a major
league game
and another 3-2 and reyes draws a
lead-off walk
well he is certainly can run a little
bit so jonathan has to be aware of him
at first base
in the turret mccann's throw to second
is a little high and reyes is
ow nice tag tim finished him off
reyes broke for second and he is cut
down
and gertie wants to take a look at it i
think it falls into the category that
the call stands as called on the field
that's what it says tigers runners at
first and second only one hit
oh one loop to right center that'll drop
willy castro scores tigers on the board
here in the first
with a clutch two-out rbi single from
jorge bonifacio and nothing
taken away from daz cameron but he's
basically in the same spot as jonathan
seaver
check swing tipped it into the glove
strike three first punch out for
jonathan stever
today's starting pitch for the tigers is
spencer turnbull
and the 01 pitch and brayu lines it to
the first base side knocked down there
by candelario he steps on the bag at
first now the force is off
anderson in a rundown being chased back
toward first base
and it'll be the pitcher turnbull trying
to tag him and he's actually ran out of
the baseline
so that'll be a double play nice spencer
turnbull gets through it on 13
pitches there goes james
throw down to second is not in time
stolen base james mccann
james just took off and figures you know
what i think i can beat this
3-2 monkatta hits it well right field
side
cameron back he's at the track monkatta
sends
this one all the way to the wall it's an
rbi double you
on monkata starting to get a little hot
in the batter's box
and we're tied at one block the first
two guys didn't throw it where he wanted
to but
since then he's gotten out of it and
just
kept on rolling towards second danny
mendic is there to reel it in for round
number one
and here comes ricky and this is
probably a good thing
doesn't want the youngster to throw too
many pitches he leaves him with a very
positive performance eminence coming to
the plate
2-1 in the year left field deloitte got
it pretty good left center back to the
wall it is up and it
is out of here so the sox have the lead
and eloy hits his 13th he's driven in
35.
second base danny on the dive nice twirl
for out number two
this ball looked like it was ticketed
for right field but for this
dive now he's thinking about second base
realizing no play there
on one knee with the spin he goes to
first
well that one gets through it's runners
at the corners only one out
it doesn't it's not but the tying run in
scoring position
excellent play by danny
three and two up the middle up the
origin base hit
danny mendick one for two here's jarrod
dyson
there's a bunt back to the mound it's
turnbull and he just got him
by a step yeah one guy can be real
unhappy to see the tigers go away this
season is going to be the man at bat
[Applause]
right side beautifully done by
here comes mendic he scores
and it's 3-1 sox setting the stage for